the US Coast Guard is out in force
across Florida this morning helping with
hurricane recovery and for tearing
through the keys I'm a battered Marco
Island when it made landfall along the
Gulf Coast
so our evidence flew with a Coast Guard
crew don't be nervous first trip to the
island and got a look at the damage he's
in Clearwater Florida Carter good
morning good morning yesterday we flew
about 150 miles south with the Coast
Guard to Marco Island we spent hours in
the air surveying the damage our pilots
were surprised by some of what they saw
and so were we lot of stuff down over
here right from 500 feet in the air the
area around Marco Island looks like a
disaster zone
heavy rains turned this neighborhood of
mobile homes into a lake it looks like
there was like a boat lift or something
a fellow we surveyed the area with
members of the US Coast Guard
two days after Emma made landfall here
is a category three storm 135
mile-per-hour winds ripped off roof
tiles in siding from homes right here
about one o'clock protective screens
around pools completely buckled and a
powerful storm surge crushed docks along
the water take a look at the homes
streets down here it looks deserted and
it pretty much but authorities are
beginning to allow residents to come
back there is a strict curfew though
residents are being asked to stay inside
their homes during the day so emergency
crews can access the area along the
coastline damaged and sinking boats dot
the mangrove lawn channels big catamaran
right there the Coast Guard's next job
will be helping to clear them out and
ensuring safe passage now you probably
hauled heard about all the communication
problems down in the keys today the
Coast Guard is sending a convoy of 12
trucks with mobile communications
equipment they are also going to pack a
c-130 airplane with as much water as it
can carry and send it to Key West this
afternoon
Nora well that will be that people will
be very very grateful for that Carter
thank you so much